Film Courage: Your film BIRDS OF PASSAGE [Pájaros
de verano] is about Colombia.
Why is it so personal to the two of you?
Cristina Gallego, Co-Director: It’s a personal
story.
I think even when you’re in a context during
a period film but you are doing a film also
that is set in a community that doesn’t
belong to you.
At the same time it speaks about us.
This is a family film and we struggle also
with the conflicts of the traditional (a community)
and the modernity that also talk about the
conflict between woman and man and the real
and the spiritual world and this is something
that touches us in a very deep way.
Film Courage: Ciro I think you said in the
press notes that you wanted to make a movie
that was not turning criminals into heroes,
showing the horrors of untamed capitalism.
So I know this is a very popular theme but
the way the two of you have shown this film
exhibits the families and more of the emotional
need behind it (for honor, respect).
Can you talk about that and why you didn’t
want to turn it into more of one of the popular
shows that is on currently?
Ciro Guerra, Co-Director: Yes, we wanted to make
a genre film but this story gave us the opportunity
to give it a twist to the genre film, like
the gangster film or the noir film that usually
has turned into a glorification of criminals,
a celebration of violence, we wanted to talk
about this process, what the birth of has
meant in Colombia which is a process of a
destruction of our cultural roots, a process
of destruction of the basis of society, a
process of destruction of a family that was
very close-knit.
And in that process you cannot glorify the
violence that takes place.
The fact that this story happened within a
society that is matrilineal in which the women
are so strong allowed us to give a twist to
the genre and make it from more of a female
perspective with a female director and strong
female characters and also we decided to every
element that is usually a celebration of violence
like the action sequences or the excitement
sequences that we were going to keep most
of the violence off-screen.
And when we kept it on-screen there was not
going to be any way of cutting it to make
it more exciting or more action driven but
it was going to be more about watching the
way that violence and destruction happens
in front of you with a distance.
Film Courage: And I understand Cristina this
is your directorial debut (I know you produced
many other films).
Was there a story that you can pass along
where something happened on set that didn’t
go as planned and you had to think on your
feet?
As a first-time director, how was that?
Cristina: I think for me as a first-time director
everything also was new and that is how I
like to work, being challenged all the time,
getting out from a place of comfort and this
film has many things and difficulties not
just for me as a first-time director but for
us and for our crew.
It was the most challenging shooting that
we have until now.
And it was just challenging me all the time
to get the concentration to be alive until
the end of the shooting because it was very
hard for us.
Film Courage: Lastly I think you’ve talked
about you think faces can tell stories?
Since I’m not sure if you spoke some of
the actual native language in the film [Wayuu
people with Arawakan language] can you talk
about how you convey that to your actors because
the facial expressions were very real.
The dialogue didn’t need to be there.
You could understand what they meant [without
saying a word].
How did you convey this to your actors and
the viewers?
Ciro: For us authenticity is the most important
part in the process of casting and in the
process of acting.
And in this film we have a mix of professional
actors with non-professional actors.
And the non-professional actors are from this
region and have are people who have experience
(a life experience) which you can see and
you can feel.
And they were sharing life experience and
also the culture and the language and every
aspect of the Wayuu to the professional actors
who we were working with the and some of them
which were no Wayuu.
And also the professional actors were teaching
them the craft of cinema, how to stand on
scene, how to make the dialogue real and so
in this process where they are both learning
from each other is a growing process for both
of them and a growing process for the film
and the result is something that is very transporting
and very authentic in what we mean when we
say that a face has almost like a location,
like the main location of a film is where
the emotion happens and where the audience’s
connection happens.
Cristina: Yes, I think that as we are different
in skin and are people, each one is talking
not only his own but also about his roots
and that is something that is in the skin
and in the faces of the films.
As Ciro is saying we are looking for authenticity
not only in the faces but in the language,
in the traditions and in all of the world
that we are creating and this is part of what
we are looking for.